you look beautiful as always thank you
you look handsome as always well i don't
always look this good it's the pedicure
uh but thank you for being here i wish
you actually were barefoot under there
no you don't want to see the old webbed
toe oh big turn off for this crowd and
the ladies uh
good for the mermaid yeah i can get
through the water so fast but other than
that it's very sad i want to
congratulate you before you start
because i haven't seen you in a little
while and since
since the last time i saw you
you won a golden globe which is very
impressive but the most impressive part
you beat out meryl streep to get the
golden globe that's impossible how did
that happen
i mean good for you and you deserve it
yeah it's kind of um i would think
whenever you're up against meryl streep
it's just like well i won't even show up
exactly that's how i felt and i actually
i i worked with her i was lucky enough
to work with her in a play here in new
york and so when i saw her at the globes
i like bumped into her and was kind of
jokingly like you're going down and then
she actually did go down and
i was like see it's funny if then she
wins but when you're like you're going
down street you're going out and then
you win
that makes you look terrible
embarrassing yeah and then you held the
globe in front of her face and taunted
her exactly that's not good
now i want to ask you something it's a
big part of your career which a lot of
people don't know about
but is promotion you know you you work
hard on the movie and everybody knows
that but then you you you go places you
do a million print interviews you come
on shows like this
how do you and i've noticed you always
look loose and like you're having fun
how do you keep it loose how do you keep
it fun from just becoming repetitive and
um well
i don't know i guess it is kind of
repetitive a lot of the times but um my
publicist tries to do this thing where
you have to like she'll say a word right
before you do because we do these
junkets where you have to sit in a room
and do like 50 interviews in a row that
are four minutes each and they all ask
you exactly the same questions so she's
like try and get the word diaper in
there and like she throws out like
something random it's like a fun game
like a bat yeah exactly like how and try
and incorporate it into your answer and
it kind of messes me up all the time
because you're trying to you've noticed
a lot of your interviews are you just
talk a lot about diapers and
it's weird but do you i mean i think
that would be fun and be fun for your
publicist but probably you're trying to
talk about the movie and you're like i
still haven't worked diaper in exactly
yeah i'm like and belin at the
guillotine was really wetting her diaper
yeah yeah
i i can work it in easily to almost any
conversation but i'm an immature ass um
i you had a
united kingdom premiere for this movie
a royal premier and the royals were
there at the premiere
uh i've always heard that when you're
going to meet the royals or interact
with them there are rules that it's not
just yeah slapping five or whatever
there's there's yeah there's like this
whole protocol letter that they send you
before and they're like you must address
him by sir and her by ma'am which rhymes
with spam like they write that in the
letter they write you ma'am which rhymes
with why do they need to tell you what
other way is there to say well i guess
some people would say mom right in in
britain i guess yeah they would say mom
like right m-a-r-m so they say just they
tell you how to pronounce it are you
allowed to talk to them sort of
informally at all you can only answer
questions but you can't ask any
questions
that's how it works for me here too
if anyone ever says how are you don't
speak
portman you will answer my questions
you will do it now uh
so is it but is it fun i mean first of
all who had you met before i know that
you met prince charles charles once at
the royal premier first the first star
wars right which was um he he asked me
because you know they have like one
question they're sort of prepared so
they they ask they know like one tidbit
about every person he asked me um he
said oh were you in the original films
and i was like
not so much yeah
yes i'm 58 years old
plastic surgery she should have just hit
him in the forehead what are you
thinking
uh yeah well he's not you know he's not
really thinking about it hard but uh but
it must be really fun i would think to
do that it's it's kind of hysterical
with like the whole trumpets and
they really do that they have trumpets
right wow that's so cool yeah it's
pretty foreign coming you know to think
that your tax money goes to pay for
someone to like have trumpets call for
them and i hope our tax money isn't
going for that crap
it'd be great if american taxpayers
figured out we're supporting the king
and queen of england you know what the
hell um
it's for trumpets for the king and queen
of england
come on
uh you know what's amazing i want to
talk about this movie because i thought
i knew something about this i thought i
knew this story because you know you
i knew that okay anne boleyn married to
henry viii he decides he wants out
chops her head off we all learn that in
school
but there's so much more to the story
and it's a fascinating story and at the
same time it's very it's it's a racy
story i mean there's a lot of racy
sounds like something my grandfather
would say
you know a pretty racy story there
uh but uh
but you and scarlett johansson there's a
lot of uh
it's very romantic but very erotic at
the same time sibling rivalry yeah yeah
all kinds of you guys are competing for
the affections of of the king so it was
kind of neat because i was watching the
movie and i was like i'm learning and
it's sexy
which didn't happen a lot when i was in
school
absolutely yeah it's very history
through porn
[Applause]
why didn't you use that on the poster
the other bowling girl history through
porn
lines around the block
uh well it is it is a fascinating story
i don't i don't know how much you want
me to give away because i don't want to
ruin it for people but uh this is the
story basically you play anne boleyn
and scarlett johansson is your sister
and you are both rivals for henry viii's
affections right and i know we have a
clip here what do we need to know for
this clip um well anne is sort of
banished for being cheeky with the king
and so she this is her big return to
court when he's sort of saying oh
are you good enough to come back to
court right and he's sort of interested
in her but he's not sure and this is
where and and you've got a you've got a
sharp tongue yeah which is uh let's take
a look at this uh clip from the other
bowline girl
a great king
a great man
rises above such things
and what would you know of great men
i've read enough books and heard enough
talk
to believe i had no one
if you were before me
then look about you
i'm curious
do you see one here
looking my lord
still looking my lord
ah
there
found one
she's got guts
uh
very
i have to ask you one question before
before we go to commercial i just have
to ask you one question there's a rumor
out there and i just have to ask you
that uh that there's this rumor that's
going around and it's just sounded like
such a cool idea that that you were
going to do a movie or that you were
offered a movie directed by jet li
where you're a kung fu it's a kung fu
version of snow
white and i heard that and i was like
gently kung fu version of snow white
that's the greatest thing i've ever
heard
you and seven ninjas and like just
i mean it's it exists and it was it was
offered i'm not i'm not planning to do
it but
no
but it is a fantastic idea
kung fu versions of every fairy tale all
right i'm gonna convince you to do it
and you're gonna come back and promote
that film maybe you can be in it yes
which one would i be
webb towie
[Laughter]
the unknown
little guy uh
the other bowling girl you should see
this it's a great movie uh opens in
theaters tomorrow natalie portman so
nice to see you again thanks for being
here yeah we'll be right back robert
schindler's here stick around